ladies and gentlemen did you know
solomon grundy was born on a monday we
are going to watch superman and lois
episode 4 today
no beanie just flat hair that's greg's
motto for today hit that like button if
you wish you could fly faster than a
speeding bullet also subscribe and click
that notification bell if you think
krypton deserved to be blown into paces
full-length watch alongs where you sync
up with the time code guess where
they're at that's right that's right
blind waves patreon page we have joined
up with them full length watch alongs
over there check out all the content
that we got to offer
lastly thanks to the boys over at
prepper for helping us edit down these
videos you guys are just
so kind to us to do this for free
let's swing into action people
there is a hole inside of me and i
thought staying here with you would fill
it but it won't i see you but you can't
help me and ally can
she already has oh no
i don't force any of my congregants to
do anything they don't want to do so the
inverse society is a religion now
call it whatever you like how about a
cult
but not that
anything with that i am gonna make sure
that lucy
and everyone else you have infected
sees you for the absolute fraud that you
are
and then i'm going to take you down once
and for all
lois oh [ __ ] i don't respond well to
threats lewis
neither do i super bad
murder
get out this
i'm the beacon
you were right we need to find my sister
and lucy
there's that fire breath
memory link
everything is so bizarre
she's been listening to that podcast all
morning don't use your superhearing on
your mother okay
trust me
she'll talk so much [ __ ] about you man
you hear a lot of uncomfortable stuff
she's so far gone
so find a way to bring her back
i'm gonna try
john hunter irons
can you go get lucy for me
we're about to have the best quinceanera
that smallville has ever seen
it's the first time they've spoken
spanish in years
dean i think he's trying to dick up your
past and use it against you they were
asking about sarah too i appreciate it
emily thank you this is a cutthroat
small town it's a problem when everyone
knows each other
it's been nice
showing the boys something other than
the city nah for that too
she's really starting to like it here
nothing will change that
[Music]
oh
it's coming here you know he's showing
up
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no
[Music]
i love the music
or something yeah it's backwards
oh
no
you're not wearing your gauntlet john
now
ouch
[Music]
almost looked like he had more skin tone
when he went off the dark web the place
where the real creepers hang out which
is where i have been catfishing all
night using probably my best alias go
chrissy nelly collins penny for short
she's a young impressionable blonde from
iowa said he's struggling to find
herself that name sounds familiar yeah
honor she has come so far what if this
sets her back
she is stronger than you think
we're just gonna have to trust her she
should have a heads up at least probably
please tell her to look out for people
creeping around for info well for me i
mainly feel stronger but
when kendall took it
she swears she hurt her mom at work a
couple miles away oh
no i don't really know if it's my thing
just so you know timmy he bought like
five inhalers on saturday so it might be
pretty tough to beat without some help
you're awful
yeah
there's a very specific energy signature
which we now have
i saw what that thing did to you with
the minds you need help and there's
probably nobody better to ask than
anderson and that team of his
super men
super friends so is is this why you're
not doing cheer anymore yeah pretty much
but also the girl's gotten like really
weird since kenneth became captain i
don't no offense none taken john's never
had the best taste in women
it's too bad it's cute
oh
what do i have to do
clean up your jacket
yes
vanquish these criminals
[Music]
hey
cushy it's it's cool my dad has the
whole place under surveillance oh
no
jordan
there are finally some real stakes in
this show
just laser the security camera i
scrambled the original how did you son i
used to run the united states department
of defense cleaning this up is easier
than candy crush a little to the left he
would have been in a blind spot
tips from grandpa
i can do this
all right just go in there
look for my sister if you see her text
me got it oh crap she's gonna join the
cult just to get brainwashed if you
don't know
what's missing you're never gonna be
able to find it that's why you're here
today
with me so that i can show you
what that missing piece is
oh man she's too drawn wasn't keeping
anything from you
we'll see what we can find you find it
you let me know you're in no condition
to stop anything your team isn't ready
general i have to do this alone so
please just let me know say the pleasure
of allegiance
and we can talk
yeah send that resettle
yeah right here on the sidelines
i really would have gotten more familiar
with how this works first
nah just trying the right practice
it's got practice for a reason
[Music]
kryptonite fix all for everything timmy
you're fired i love it that takes some
five minutes
please it's the least you could do for
me after you sent ali to meet me instead
of you fine
room 452
come alone just not right now this hole
that we carry
this deep deep pain
is one that only we can heal ourselves
with xenu because once the person who
deceived us
gets away with it that pain
never goes away oh isn't that right miss
beppo
hmm
i i'm penny awkward you hide the truth
to fit your own special narrative
lois lane is the best reporter i've ever
met
you should meet more reporters
i understand your confusion
but maybe this will help change your
mind your article on ally wasn't what we
agreed on
why didn't you publish what i saw
because i was trying to protect you you
sounded insane ally was right and you
know it she's a monster i know that was
not easy to hear christine how about the
fact how [ __ ] up it is
surveillance
you heard that yeah i heard
ali broadcasted for the whole room to
see there's a lot more to this article
than you first led me to believe
you really don't trust me do you chrissy
i can explain
so if that ignorant loser wants to
attack me then fine let him i'd love to
get up on that debate stage and tell
everybody what i think about that
country fried ass no well i thought she
was gonna say the superhero
what are you doing no that bird was
gonna hit me
that bird way over there honestly you
know what i think it's probably this new
medication i've been thinking look a
little friendly advice maybe
maybe stop taking those meds no not yet
not until it gets nice and bad you sure
it's the same energy signature yes sir
satellites confirm are you ready
you sure we don't need to alert superman
sir he's in no shape to fight this thing
bring it here cool
that's not superman
uh supposed to be really upset for the
episode
we're the superman of america and we
need you to come with us
oh yeah
that's the sound of everything oh [ __ ]
this team to stop this guy can they two
are already dead don't kill tag
grab it go
those
your suit is a 10 functionality john the
hammer is low on energy and defense
shields have been severely compromised
you're just here for moral support turn
around
go home
damn
that's not gonna end well
oh my god
[Music]
stop hitting yourself stop hitting
yourself
[Music]
ah [ __ ]
[Music]
you got bodies to bring back
oh man that was crazy
oh i thought that door handle was coming
out
well mom
what are you doing
[Laughter]
just come at me like that give me some
warning
how could you let this happen
just go
just leave us alone
well if it isn't my favorite public
servant don't you listen here you smoke
son of a [ __ ]
hold up kyle
i'm gonna be watching you
well that goes two ways kyle for a man
who likes his tequila neat
word around town is you sure can get
messy with it
[Music]
don't let him get in your head that's
just what he wants
hey you're so burnt out that's all that
matters
okay
yeah damn this guy knows how to make him
feel i think his whole family feels
ashamed all's fair in politics with
everything that's happened recently i
i think i should be ready to help that
i want you to train me okay
go get some rest
you're gonna need it gotta learn how to
use a gun in the morning
it made me at 0-500
[Laughter]
no longer in school
you're bad
oh [ __ ] kyle what are you doing dude
he's not so brizzy get on that wagon
buddy or i've missed you around here
but not nearly as much as i oh
yeah it's actually uh what i came here
to talk to you about
oh
no
[Music]
kyle lana's so fine
whatever i have to do to stop her i will
not even you can stop the truth from
coming out
watch me
oh
damn this episode's like a psychological
thriller can you meet me
i want you to tell me the truth about
lois
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
you are so annoying sometimes
[Music]
chrissy
oh god
you can really get on my nerves i'm
serious
it's okay
i feel you
hey she's seen a lot
but if she were a man i wouldn't have a
problem
i don't trust that lois lane go look
into her yeah
i know women
always trying to bend the truth
[Laughter]
well after last week's tease this
episode delivered with non-stop bizarro
that's right man jeez give us a break
get back to the other story anyone else
doing
what's any other character other than
bizarro doing please um
what exactly was
lois
what what's your interp your take on
everything lois was hiding exactly
i
uh a little a little muddy on that we
could play it back but yeah why do that
i mean she she hid the part where it
seemed as though like she hid the most
compellingly debatable part which is was
lucy actually glimpsing her other self
on the other side of whatever void this
is that she got that place that she got
to when she took all those pills
uh or was that just a drug-addled
hallucination and i guess that whole bit
was kept
which is the linchpin to the legitimacy
of the ally alliston thing
is uh
the main thing it seems like it was
messed up that she withheld that's what
i got from it yeah
oh chrissy you are just so
[ __ ] frustrating sometimes like
not even
not even like a second
she's already kind of frustrating the
first two episodes of
podcast says this i don't trust you yeah
yeah yeah yeah and just constantly every
time you check back whether it's just
obsessing over the podcast and then this
happens and you're like come on all
right again it's not a hundred percent
the the what like what is this dream
chrissy has of like that
um
she wants just like the purest
to
the purest the pure journalism and i get
that like i get it i do believe me i do
simultaneously it's like do you not have
a history with this woman do you not
have like
an amount of good was none you're like
completely disregarding any goodwill
she had her sister involved it wasn't
just some like personal bias of a
situation
in the terms of like i met you and i
formed a bias based off of this it was
like it was her sister and she
has also made witness to a lot more of
her behavior than just this whole thing
with
uh ally
al alliston all right alliston yeah
austin
i don't know all right i just i think
that like
being upset
totally valid like if you're upset like
you didn't tell me the whole truth
totally get it but then to be like
ally
tell me the truth about lois like jesus
christ
talk to lois it is so frustrating
it is so frustrating it really
it pisses me off of all the things i do
feel like that story could use an
additional shade of nuance and they do
it with lois and they do it with lucy
but when it comes to chrissy i feel like
yeah and maybe it's just because in a
show with a lot of story lines to
maintain it's not the highest priority
but yeah like some
additional shade of new one like i don't
begrudge for the suspicion and the
somewhat dismay
but yeah the way it's handled it so far
feels like you just really don't trust
lois at all
and just like any kind of attempt like
it has to be part of and i grant she's
at a smaller town newspaper that's where
her experience comes from but i don't
know like reporters especially involved
in a situation like that i'm sure would
be embroiled in some level of
controversy and that would be to be
expected
so like yeah i don't know some tempering
of that or maybe a little bit of lowest
benefit of the doubt would be nice
or a little bit of acknowledgement
that clearly ally and lucy worked
together to manipulate chrissy to come
over there in the whole conference this
whole thing was for you this whole
seminar was based around
placing a hidden camera there so lucy
can
feign
being hurt so that way because i was
like man something's up with this
chick's acting like
that that she said sorry just sounding
actually very real when she like
revealed what she was really doing yeah
there we go
um
and uh yeah so it's like this whole
thing is so manipulative it's it it's
and
granted like yes she's being a
journalist and sneaking in and being
undercover and did her manipulative
thing too but i'm like
but
come on like
you can't just suddenly throw your tr
like it just seems like any time
something's said about her
chrissy just doubts lois and just
believes it immediately yeah instead of
just being like it was your sister and i
get
that she would have sounded like she was
tripping on drugs yeah yeah
yeah
yeah there or or you know i don't know
for as much as i get also the whole
thing about like when it's your family
it's different rules i don't know like
it seems like yeah you could at least
understand the the difficulty and the
grayness of the overall situation enough
to be like wow this is
a really big mess of a situation i have
to deal with not like oh you're you're a
militia you're a reporter of malicious
intent you know or something like that
but hopefully it gets ironic part is i
really like the episode a lot
i'm rooting for her storyline to pick up
i don't know i mean maybe in the next
episode she'll go in with the guys of
like tell me all about lois but hey
hopefully she'll have her reporter hat
on to also
have a suspicious eye on ellie alliston
she's like she's
clowns clearly
occultly she's clearly got that pollen
let me have a meeting with lois and boom
secret men regarding everyone in the bar
is a secret person of mine and the copy
i was saying such [ __ ] guys come on
yeah
um but no i mean this whole episode was
pretty much dealing with people making
mistakes and the consequences of those
mistakes rash decisions
jonathan taking xk good for him
good for him take your xk yeah get those
football scholarships i really do like
story lines about people who take
a substance that really enhances their
senses yeah where they're
like freaking
awesome whatever it is they want to do
they have they have movie autism at that
point where they just notice every
detail and are great at everything yeah
yeah they're a bit jumpy
uh i did like i did like uh him doing
that because
it's about time jonathan broke bad a
little bit yes
it really is yeah and i'm excited to see
where that goes to
how many more birds attack him that
girlfriend of his is a freaking little
drug addict manipulator yeah she's
supplying like the whole town with this
jonathan's like i don't want to do it
she's like hi
i love you
just know for your competition bought
like five of them the other day
so just saying
do what you want though like hey i
respect it i respect respect be a tea
totaler and but i'm definitely pushing
but also if you want to have any
self-esteem whatsoever
by the end of the season you better
i mean yeah it's like people trying to
preserve their morals no matter what
this got brought up a lot i expressed
this in the
reaction
um
in last week's episode but not during
the review i didn't really dive into it
was how people were upset with sarah
um like we were making our jokes about
it because it was like but you still
cheated and
why is jordan making look like he's the
bad guy in the situation and saw that i
saw that echoed a lot in the comments on
last week's episode
it's like a lot of that's not really
somehow it's like they treat jordan like
you you you need to like just forgive
her and move on
and uh
i wasn't like super bothered by it but i
definitely noticed it in the show i see
it rubbed a lot of people the wrong way
there's a layer again another layer of
nuance they could have put on that
yeah it was like jordan doesn't deserve
you if he doesn't come back
yeah
yeah if he doesn't yeah it's like i like
the whole thing about you know there's
something to be said for the fact that
she just came to him and said it but
also yeah it's totally reasonably to be
like also you violated the trust that we
yeah i left off with
and uh and then so with this episode
though
the way they're painting sarah is
interesting it just seems like no matter
what you ain't going to shame this girl
yeah let's see how well that holds up
yeah because this mayor guy he knows how
to just get right underneath your skin
yeah and he does have the dirt on people
he's flat out cheating he alley-oops
sarah's a pawn this lana is better
looking than a bartender i know
maybe kyle got so drunk he thought it
was hard the actors are watching this
reaction
hey we're part of that and you're just
just
feeling it over there she's super happy
for all the comments
weird part about doing these and when
you find out like oh they watch this
i'm sorry i'm bad i didn't mean it
rephrase everything i've ever said i'm
just thinking about the characters yeah
man
um
infidelity man is bad i know what a dumb
ass
just thought how i was doing it
everyone's making terrible mistakes so i
like a show that challenges your
characters absolutely
it's a bit of a slingshot
admittedly though because it's like wow
we are really challenging our characters
because yeah last season you know kyle
had his problems and [ __ ] but uh this
time around they're like let's really
let everyone make some bad choices yeah
let's do things that are not right and
let's let people in town really get
under each other's skin
yeah yeah no i like it though like
usually a season one would have a little
bit more of that planted throughout and
then this one's this season just going
not jonathan's getting on drugs lois is
not a fully honest reporter sometimes
and uh what was the other one kyle's a
cheater that was a cheater
and uh sarah had a suicide of
temperature sarah's a cheater sarah's a
cheater too yeah runs the family there
you go
uh but yes and uh clark gets john henry
into too many dangerous scenarios i know
but barely a weird thing to follow up
bizarro with like not much focus
yeah
yeah it seems like like clark's
involvement in this episode him and
bizarro both was was mostly physical and
mostly i mean you know there's obviously
all physical
and mostly develop you know further
stakes with john henry really and to
show how like outmatched the super
friends are the super men of america or
whatever they call themselves
yeah superman of america and uh that was
a cool fight though they had between
them yeah but yeah we didn't really
what music is that is that it's
obviously being played in reverse
is it the superman is it the score of
this i would have to imagine like i bet
they would take clark's light motif or
whatever and then reverse it or or
something if there's a register yeah if
there's like a specific superman suite
they had that that would be my that
would make the most sense to me yeah but
yeah like it's funny because that's such
a big reveal and while i liked all the
bizarro stuff here it didn't feel like
it built on that almost at all
well also superman didn't ask john henry
to show up i mean it was still the guilt
though of not protecting him yeah john
henry is always luck
um i need it
all right i'll come in i'm jumping in
let me just grab i like i like the
realism of that too i'm like ooh that's
got hurt yeah you got it bro yeah good
luck with that hand that's cool and yeah
him showing up to help save the day too
bizarre does seem like a threat but
what's happening here like clark is like
weakened right when he's around him
somehow clark is uh
just not as strong it's not fair i
couldn't tell fair to do
i couldn't tell if it was like a hancock
thing almost was like the closer they
get to each other the more different
effects that it seemed like as the
episode went on clark was able to at
least gain some power
control against bizarro yeah yeah
punched him did that like flying in the
air right hook thing a billion times
yeah so i don't i can't really tell
um i like the i like that they've really
established like that they're kind of
seeing through each other's eyes and
things like that but it really does get
me curious about what
you know it doesn't seem like this is
verbatim you know obviously like the
classic bizarro so it makes me wonder
what themes of that character's general
story they're gonna take and how they're
going to play it because i feel like
from what little i know about the finer
workings of bizarro the character
there's like a frankenstein monster
aspect
where that doesn't really feel like what
it is right now i mean it feels a lot
more outwardly menacing and a lot more
outwardly chaotic but i don't know i'm
excited i'm eager
to see how they start to address
how do you get here you know like what
is the nature of this universe is
bizarro i think he's gonna kill lois and
work with the people who
brought him to life to resurrect her yes
as bizarro lois yeah making the bride
make her the bride yeah yeah so
she's alive
yeah and then we'll have like a romance
for the second half of the season
between the bizarros they'll move into
the
the farm across the way
do you think if jonathan had powers the
xk would activate it in some way
yeah
which again yeah that's a good point i
hadn't
i hadn't touched on that but yeah
there's that still lingering question of
is he just a normal boy
or yeah is this gonna awaken something
although i feel like my money would be
on that that this is the extent of like
whatever xk gives him his is his power
but he doesn't innately have it yeah
all right guys well we are done for the
day
we will see you soon bye
[Music]